Are you watching a WandVision, Andy?
Have you seen the show yet?
I have not.
I'm gonna tell you, it's fantastic.
It's one of those shows you
can watch with the whole family
and my kids love it and it's so well done.
It's beautifully done.
All right, I'll watch it with your kids.
I'd prefer you watched it-
No, my kids have seen it
and they watch it with me.
I don't think you need to
watch it with my children.
I'm getting mixed messages here.
(laughing)
Okay, all right.
Well, maybe I'll come over to your house
and I'll watch it with you.
How's that?
And we'll leave the kids out of it.
Okay.
[Conan] All right.
I'm lonely.
(laughing)
Why do you say it in such a happy way?
I don't know.
I'm excited about having you come over.
Are you feeling a little more optimistic
about the the whole pandemic thing now?
Don't you feel?
I got to say every day that goes by
I think we're getting closer
towards the end of this thing.
Is that possible?
Well, I mean there, isn't it like,
they're vaccinating a
million people a day now?
That's got to make a difference.
Yeah and now they have a third,
there's a third vaccine,
the Johnson & Johnson.
Fantastic.
I think they should
just go down the street
darting people with the vaccine.
Wouldn't it be great.
I'd love it.
You and I have not been vaccinated yet.
I'd love it if that was
just walking down the street
on my way to get a frozen yogurt.
Ah, vaccinated.
Ah.
[Conan] Hey, you know?
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, but as I said last night
we got to wait until our category comes up
and you know what that category is.
Tell 'em.
National treasures.
[Andy] Yeah.
That would be.
(laughing)
I just love the idea
that anyone watching at home
would get angry at that.
[Andy] Yeah, yeah.
You're not a national treasure.
Who do you think you are?
And you know what, people say,
oh, I really miss socializing,
going to the clubs,
things like that.
I didn't do those things before COVID.
No.
No one wanted me to go
to the clubs with them.
No.
Yeah, you've been practicing.
Yeah.
[Andy] Yeah.
Yeah, I was practicing for COVID
long before COVID came along.
[Andy] Right.
Sona, did anyone ever want
me to go clubbing with them?
Okay, all right.
You could've just said no to no clubbing.
You didn't have to say
no one ever wanted you to go anywhere.
All right.
Just stay back behind that curtain, okay?
No reason for you to come out.
Yeah.